le chef du parti populaire du canal est
avec nous maxime bernier bonsoir bonsoir
alors on parlait des sondages tout à
l'heure mais malgré votre présence à un
débat en anglais où vous avez eu
beaucoup de visibilité
les chiffres ne bougent pas pour vous
vous êtes toujours à peu près à 3% des
intentions de vote comment vous recevez
ça bien je doute un peu les sondages le
vrai sondage bva être le 21 octobre mais
il faut dire que le soir du débat en
anglais pendant leur la première heure
et c'est la première heure où j'ai eu
plus de visibilité sur google le mot le
plus recherché était people's party of
canada donc ça me dit que les gens ont
voulu en savoir plus sur notre parti sur
notre plateforme et moi c'était le but
de ces débats là de parler oui
l'immigration il doit parler notre
plateforme et on va voir qu'est-ce qui
va arriver dans quelques jours mais ça
va peut-être pas si bien que ça parce
qu'aujourd'hui le winnipeg free press
rapporte qu'un nouveau candidat à
quitter le navire et il dit je cite là
que votre formation et raciste et
intolérante
comment est ce que pouvait rallier les
canadiens justement avons politique
monsieur bernier si même vos propres
candidats quittent parce que c'est le
deuxième en quelques jours ses propres
candidats quittent le parfait ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que nos candidats
on est des candidats de religion
musulmane de religion juive de toute
forme de religion qui existent et ils
font partie ils sont avec nous pour les
valeurs qu'on peut partager les valeurs
qu'on croit les valeurs de liberté de
responsabilité de respect et c'est
complètement faux nous on est là et on
finit par une position un peu extrêmes
si drôle sur l'environnement sur
l'environnement c'est une position qui
est importante on a parlé
d'environnement aussi et donc c'est les
gens sont intéressés par sa je veux
qu'on évolue encore plus saint laurent
le 2 215 milliards de litres qui sont
envoyées dans nos rivières partout dans
le canada sur l'immigration va avoir un
vrai débat et c'est là je me suis
environnement parlons-en passé lors du
débat de lundi vous avez dit quelque
chose qui en a fait sursauter bruges a
pas ce que vous avez dit je suis le plus
environnementalisme de tous les chefs
mais comment vous pouvez dire monsieur
berniche parce que vous voulez vous
retirer des accords de paris vous ne
croyez pas à l'urgence climatique vous
et annulé la taxe carbone oui même vous
en est pris à l' icône du mouvement
environnemental il a t'on laissez-moi
répondre à votre question effectivement
tous les autres chefs de partis disent
qu'ils vont être capables d'atteindre
les cibles de l'accord de paris et c'est
complètement faux même le nul dit les
experts le disent apprend une taxe sur
le carbone de 300 dollars la tonne pour
être capable pour que le canada puisse
atteindre les sites de pari donc les
autres chefs qui me disent qu'ils vont
atteindre les sites de pari ils sont
hypocrites ans dans la population et
deuxièmement le canada représente pour
polluer ce qu'il faut pas payer un prix
quand on pollue est-ce qu'on pollue
indûment monsieur deuxièmement le canada
représente 1,6 pour cent des émissions
globales de gaz à effet de serre
lorsqu'on me dit qu'on va sauver la
planète et sauver le climat c'est
complètement faux moi ce que je lis faut
faire des choses concrètes des actions
concrètes pour l'environnement c'est ce
qui préoccupe les gens et c'est pour ça
aujourd'hui hier j'ai fait une
conférence de presse en parlant
justement de nos cours d'eau on achetait
encore des eaux usées dans le fleuve
saint-laurent et une étude qui est sorti
de l'environnement qu'un des
environnements qu'un des manques de
ressources pour faire ces études là
les règlements sont pas assez sévères
faisons des actions concrètes
aujourd'hui prédit l'environnement et si
ça ne pas améliorer la qualité de l'eau
monsieur bernier ses lois mais si bien
il ya personne qui contre ça pour nous
l'heure actuelle que s'ils disent que
c'est ça qui est le plus important
actuellement les policiers dépenses 2,6
milliards de dollars c'est ce que
monsieur trudeau a fait pour lutter
contre les changements climatiques dans
les pays en voie de développement
moi je dis on doit rapatrier ça ici et
aider vraiment notre environnement et
les canadiens d'abord le canada s'est
engagé à verser de l'argent dans un
fonds global pour aider les pays les
plus pauvres à des changements et des
plans pour se protéger des changements
climatiques c'est là qu'on dise à 100
millions seulement de cet argent qui a
été versée j'essaie mais c'est là qu'on
diffère c'est là qu'on diffère moi je
pense qu'on va utiliser l'argent ici
pour aider les canadiens de la peau
mélanome ans maxime bernier justement
pour lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique mais bien je laisse ça aux
provinces
je laisse ça aux provinces mois général
ne ferait rien absolument pas les
provinces exact la gare de regarder la
taxe sur le carbone aujourd'hui ne
s'applique pas au québec parce que le
québec des jeunes politique de bourse de
carbone donc le taxe ne s'applique pas
je laisse les provinces
l'environnement est une est une
compétence partagée je laisse les
provinces occupé des changements
climatiques
moi je dis qu'il
d'urgence climatique mais au fédéral on
doit s'occuper des actions concrètes
pour l'environnement et c'est ce que
j'annonce et c'est ce qu'on veut faire
vous dites pas d'urgence climatique mais
il ya des périodes de sécheresses des
vagues de chaleur on en vit déjà les
conséquences
il y avait 1 30% des espèces animales
qui sont en voie d'extinction les
conséquences entre suppression des
sommes à l'amga dépôt il ya plus de 400
scientifiques européens qui ont créé une
lettre au secrétaire de l'onu en dix ans
des scientifiques en disant qu'il n'y a
pas d'urgence climatique et vous faut
pour faire faut faire attention et la
distinction entre scientifique monsieur
bernier mais c'est quand même vous allez
à l'encontre quand même du consensus
scientifique 97% des études sur le
réchauffement climatique depuis 30 ans
mais est ce que c'est un acquis
important science et pour le consensus
c'est la raison c'est l'effet et
d'autres scientifiques comme exemple
patrick moore qui est un scientifique
très réputé ici au canada qui était un
co co fondateur du mouvement greenpeace
qui dit aussi qu'il n'y a pas d'urgence
climatique
patrick mohr parlons-en parce que vous
le citez souvent donald trump le site
souvent c'est un peu la tête d'affiche
des climato sceptiques
c'est quelqu'un qui n'a pas fondé le
bois des profondeurs arrivé plus tard
dans le mouvement et en plus on sait
maintenant que c'est un lobby et s'il
est payé par l'industrie des industries
minières forestières pour justement
semer un doute sur le réchauffement qui
absolument pas vous avez dit que je suis
cuit mais tous écrits proxy donald
chemin je suis pas qu'ils mettent aux
sceptiques le climat change doit
toujours changer il faut votation sa
température et le combat oui je
reconnais ça c'est un fait et le climat
a changé il ya douze mille ans et si on
était sous la glace il ça va changer et
oui un vrai changement réchauffement
climatique mais pas de panique à agir
non il n'a pas de panique parce que la
raison principale du changement
climatique et pas l'activité de l'homme
sur la terre est pas le co2 et il ya
plusieurs autres facteurs et les études
sont orientés vers l'activité de co2 par
rapport aux changements climatiques moi
ce que je demande qu'on devrait faire
plus d'études sur l'impact du soleil
l'impact des océans on en fait pas de
ces étudiants actuellement on a fait
très peu pas beaucoup sur l'impact des
changements climatiques il faut encore
se questionner je vais avancer mais
quand même monsieur dernier vous dites
les faits vous dites que vous voulez des
faits mais 97 % de toutes les études qui
ont été faites par le gie
avec depuis 30 ans disent que le
réchauffement climatique est inquiétant
et qu'il est causé par l'activité
humaine rencontre des faits c'est une
des raisons non j'en parle en compte des
filles d'autres scientifiques qui
prendre autre chose et c'est une des
raisons mais c'est pas la raison
principale si vous donnez pas la raison
principale
alors parlons de l'immigration d'une
autre un autre niveau position là dessus
sont aussi controversé voulait réduire
donc l'immigration oui rien de
controversé monsieur legault deal à 158
quand même beaucoup ça monsieur n'est
absolument pas ce qu'on veut plus
d'immigrants économiques regard du
québec monsieur legault et oui sur la
peur mais comme d'un match en plus est
ce que monsieur legault joie sur la peur
il voulu et on va voir au québec 10
millimes grand de moins regardez
monsieur legault veut moins de réfugiés
et plus d'immigrants nature économique
pour combler les besoins ici économique
au québec je suis le seul chef qui
répond à cette demande
les onze chefs ne veulent pas diminuer
le nombre de réfugiés qu'on reçoit ici
au canada
nous notre proposition c'est on va avoir
moins d'immigrants globalement un
maximum de 150 milles mais 50% de ces
gens là au lieu de 26% aujourd'hui
doivent être des énergies sur 53 % les
lazy millions et 50% et ses 26 % parce
qu'ils comptent la famille immédiate moi
ce que je dis la personne qui vient
travailler bien travaillé c'est le
travailleur ya 26 % de gens qui viennent
travailler parce qu'on a besoin de leur
qualité mais de leurs compétences
mais ces gens là viennent oui avec leurs
familles mais ce qu'on en a besoin on a
besoin de plus un nombre plus élevé pour
ce faire faut avoir moins d - de
réfugiés et c'est ce que veut le garant
du québec
donc nos propositions politiques
reprennent représente très bien si les
chiffres de 150000 vous le basé sur quoi
je le bats sûr je pense qu'on a des
besoins de main d'oeuvre les besoins de
main d'oeuvre les besoins mais ce mais
actuellement ce pas ce concombre
on a 45 mille faux réfugiés qui sont
venus au canada en passant par la route
roxane il faut régler ça on est seul
parti qui va le régler mais c'est
injuste parce que les vrais réfugiés qui
attendent dans des camps où leur vie est
en danger quelque part ne peuvent pas
venir aucun aide
on peut pas on fait j'en profite d'une
entente qu'on a avec les étages liste un
peu compliqué ils peuvent pas rentrer et
légalement monsieur bernier il faut il
faut choisir il faut choisir nos
immigrants il faut choisir nous réfugier
aussi ces gens là on rentre ici parce
que l'entente n'est pas respectée ce
qu'il faut faire pour le faire respecter
mais il faut aussi s'assurer d'aider les
vrais réfugiés ces gens là viennent ici
pour avoir de meilleures conditions
économiques
dites moi pas quelqu'un qui vient
détendu york sa vie est en danger si on
veut être vraiment généreux et des avait
expulsé par le gouvernement de monsieur
par l'administration job il ya ils
viennent de vie est bien de pays tiers
sûr et donc de siviriez vous voudriez
construire un mur comme absolument pas
on le dit une petite barrière à la route
roczen mais on va dirigeants oui on va
dire aux gens vous êtes bienvenus au
canada mais passer par l'entrée
principale compte monsieur les français
ils vont on va les retourner aux états
unis parce qu'ils sont pas des vrais
réfugiés plus de 40% de ces gens là vont
être déporté dans trois ans ou quatre
ans et le ministère de l'immigration qui
le dit parce qu'ils sont des faux
réfugiés
pourquoi qu'on accepte des fous réfugiés
le coup c'est 350 millions par année des
obligations internationales les
obligations ben oui on peut les
respecter avec en aidant vraiment les
vrais réfugiés qui sont dans des cas il
faut le canada est un pays souverain
faut il faut choisir nouveau nos
immigrés nous réfugier comme on l'a
toujours fait et actuellement on ne fait
plus alors vous aurez sûrement
l'occasion d'en discuter demain pays bas
2e débat en français on va souhaiter un
bon débat une bonne fin de campagne
merci mais ce dernier doit il vous
remercie